look at the show of a time-travel
anybody can come back
[Music]
so Doctor Who time again and I want to
try and be a little more positive with
some of the things I've got going on
lately I've had to point out that I've
seen in am negative mode lately I don't
mean to be like it just in general just
seems like stuff keeps happening that I
I am the being disappointed by
frustrated by angered by so let me talk
about some stuff that I kind of makes me
more happy to think about which doctor
who tends to do anyway but specifically
I'm gonna talk about this time some
characters from classic who who as yet
have not made the transition to new who
that I think should that I think there
is story potential or in some cases I
just kind of want to see them again
so there isn't a ton of rhyme or reason
to this that's not a number of different
characters there's some villains of some
supporting characters let's just get
into this and if you're thinking that
eight seems like an awkward number that
it why isn't it ten because I don't pad
my lists if I can't organically come up
with ten I'm not gonna force ten and you
know what I'm not putting the Ronnie on
this list in an effort to pad it out
there's your spoiler warning she's not
on here so anyways let's start with
number eight the draconians now the
draconians are a race that appeared in
the frontier in space only once so this
was Third Doctor's era it was actually
the last Doctor Who story that Roger
Delgado appeared in before his is
unfortunate unfortunate death or the
last one he filmed at any rate they
might have they might have actually
aired them in a different order I'm not
gonna bother checking that in any case
the whole thing with the draconians is
as far as their hook goes is they are
well
there's they take their their names from
the phrase you know draconian laws
meanings extremely strict extremely
tough they are really all about honoring
the law the rules and sticking really
really firmly to it and I think that has
the potential to make them an
interesting complication or foil to a
situation I think it makes it harder for
it to make them the outright villains I
mean even in the story they appeared in
it was about them and earth being
manipulated into almost beginning to
attack each other so I don't think they
work in as like a straight conquering
villain but I think their nature really
makes them and like honestly you could
use them as a less jokey version of the
Judoon in a way in terms of like the
enforcement of these laws that -
possibly the Companions don't even make
any sense
until the doctor are just annoying the
doctors not the doctors not big on rules
that he himself did not come up with so
I think that I think they are due to
come back I think their look is solid
even for the time and I think it would
lend itself to being updated just a
little bit and it wouldn't take that
much just refine the look a little bit I
think they could look really cool I mean
for crying out loud
the Emperor is the guy with the highest
shoulder spikes yes I want them back
number seven Fenric Fenric is another
villain one time appearance in Doctor
Who he this was a Seventh Doctor villain
appearing in the curse of Fenric and his
boy how do I explain this guy as quickly
as I can do it he is sort of an ancient
being who was either around at the very
start of the universe or possibly came
from whatever universe existed before
the one we are currently existing in he
is an entity of pure evil the doctors
actually battled him numerous times
that's part of the story even in the
episode that he appears in even though
that's his only show appearance and let
most of these that I'm gonna talk about
have shown up in audios and novels
etcetera I am strictly talking about the
show
I talk about all this but in any case
the doctor actually has more history
with Fenric then we have actually seen
and been Burke's whole thing is the
doctor has to keep trapping him cuz if
this guy actually sort of has free rein
the damage he could do is almost
incalculable in terms of his ability to
just wreak destruction and manipulate
things into the way that he wants them
and even in a weakened state he's pretty
darn good at that
so when we last last left off with him
his body was destroyed but he had over
he had taken over somebody's body so he
lacked kapau real form but that doesn't
mean that there was no way that he could
ever come back and I have no doubt there
are many ways to do it and my main thing
here is with him being such you know
being presented as such a massively
powerful ancient evil having him only
have this one appearance feels like God
I we haven't gotten a proper scope of
the threat of this guy we should have
had to deal with him more than once and
that's kind of why I want I want him to
come back and I I kind of I I guess in a
way I would almost want him to function
as a substitute beast from the
impossible plan and the same because I
don't think the beasts should come back
just because I I think that story works
the way it does and I don't think
bringing the beast back is gonna is
gonna bring a heck of a lot but this is
a character in this in a similar vein to
the beast but who I think is much more
viable to actually have returned and
just wreck shop number 6 the Guardians
there are two Guardians there's the
black Guardian and the white Guardian
and it plays out basically exactly as
you would you would think one is on the
side of good the other is on the side of
evil and they have both either employed
or attempting to manipulate respectively
the doctor into helping them achieve
their goals or stymie the other in the
pursuit of their goals so these guys are
fairly abstract
and fairly thinly sketched and at least
for my tastes
I would keep them that way I we don't
unfortunately we don't know enough right
now about Jodi Whitaker's doctor to know
how she would react to someone like that
but like in my head if they had come
back said say like during Capaldi's era
he would have fought tooth and nail to
not get involved with these guys at all
but I could see one or the other or both
and you know it almost kind of a
push-pull thing either manipulating or
forcing his hand to get him involved in
their BS basically you know these these
two forces you know and theoretically
either one of them could be a
controlling power in the universe but
they're always just sort of going back
and forth and focusing on making sure
the other one doesn't get the upper hand
or at least that's how I have chosen to
read the to read their relationship
they're all there they're like petty
gods and I I think that there's there's
some more story goodness to be to be
gotten out of out of that premise and
I'd like to see them brought back and
reinterpret it and see how another
doctor deals with them because I've only
personally I've only ever seen the
fourth doctor dealing with them and I'd
like to see somebody else take a crack
at it
number five Dorothy Gale McShane
otherwise known as ace this was the
companion to to the Seventh Doctor not
the only companion and he did he did
have a few others early on and his run
but he this is his definitive companion
she spent the most time with him their
rapport was great and in many ways ace
was the test run for what we now think
of as the modern companion you know I
think there were steps forward made with
at least initially with Sarah Jane Smith
but even she would frequently get
written into screaming for help
scenarios
and they the writers kind of rebelled
against the the mandated to give the
companion more agency at that point in
time but when they got around to ace ace
honestly is like Rose you know point
zero point five and I feel like if
nothing else just to give proper
recognition that she was the template by
which the vast majority of modern
companions seemed to have been built
from I think she should be brought back
for just that reason alone but beyond
that I will Sofia Allred I would love to
see her interact with the doctor now
like I took the third with a female
doctor that way I would be fascinated by
that or even if it was later on down the
line I I think you could really get
something interest and I know we did the
old companion coming forward and meeting
my current doctor with Sarah Jane Smith
and that went very well first of all but
second of all that was also series two
it's been a long time since we've done
it it's been long enough that I think
we're allowed to give that another go
and not have it feel like an excessive
retread or gimmick especially because
ace is such a different character from
Sarah Jane and I just I I think that she
needs the send-off that the show never
properly gave her because the show was
put on its very long hiatus before any
closure could be granted to her and
again in the show a lot of what was
going to be planned for her character
has come out and some of it has been
appeared and co-opted and straw binding
and put into you know various other
mediums but I would really like to I'd
like to know where he send it up truly
definitively and I feel like doing that
in the show is the place to do that and
I I think so if you already can still
nail this character I I base that off of
you know having heard an audio aventure
that she appeared on I mean granted I
wasn't like super new that was still
from a while ago
but she's she can still do this part and
I would love to see more base number for
the monk now the monk is if you don't
know this character is a Time Lord and
he's introduced in a first doctor story
called the meddling monk and what he
does is exactly that he just kind of
messes around with time I mean think
about yeah he was kind of the first time
Lord that we encountered as far as he
owes being a problem that the doctor had
to deal with but the thing was he wasn't
excessively malicious he was possibly a
little uncaring about the collateral
damage of what he was doing but he's not
the master he's not trying to take
everything over but his carelessness I
think has some story possibilities I
actually I the story I always wanted to
see what the meddling monk is for his
messing around with stuff to finally
catch up with him and to have caused
such a mess that is accumulated into
that's such as either a string of
paradoxes or screw-ups that the he and
the doctor have to like go on a
buddy-cop adventure to fix everything
and there's just squabbling the whole
way and the way that the meddling monk
wants to fix things would only make them
worse and the doctor has to rein him in
but every now and then like he would he
would come up with a solution that was
outside what the doctor would think of
and it turns out to be the best solution
like this would have to be at least a
two-parter I would honestly say you
could string a series out of this
effectively make the meddling monk the
companion for it for a series that might
be a little bit too ambitious but then
that's like my dream scenario but I do
think you don't even without going that
big I think there is fun to be had with
this character that's the main thing he
is fun
number three su tech or any other being
from his race I'll take it this is the
villain from Pierre
Mars now we may have to settle for
somebody else I mean just go with
whoever the you know the inspiration for
set is I mean that there are other
Egyptian gods to to poll influence from
but su tech appears impairments of Mars
and he is the villain of that and it's
basically part of an alien race that it
turns out the Egyptian Pantheon is based
on and he is again very much kind of an
embodiment of evil the pyramid of Mars
is is a very well regarded classic who
episode I haven't done a review on again
I probably won't for a while because it
is one that I've already seen and right
now I'm kind of focusing my classic who
reviews on things that are completely
new to me but I'll get around to it
eventually I'm sure but he is an
intimidating villain he's got he's got a
good strong look he has a strong
presence and especially if you get a
doctor that can play up the the fear and
the tension and again if you can't
logistically figure out a way to have su
tech specifically come back just
somebody else from the bad end of that
Pantheon I think would be a really cool
nod I think it'd be a really big pop for
fans and I think there's just there's
there's more to be done with with this
whole idea of the pyramids being linked
to the these aliens I know that it's
that's almost like a punchline now you
know the the pyramids were built by
aliens or whatnot but the doctor who's
already still treading on that with
things like pyramid at the end of the
world so I mean idea anyone who knows da
in classic dark to how weird was it that
the Oh sirens had nothing to do with
that really that that was weird right
where's just me yeah we'll move on
number two Ramon avoid luttrell Adar
otherwise known as Romana now this is
one you could go a couple of different
ways on she's been played by more than
one actor already Lalla Ward is still
around if you wanted to bring back that
version
Romana that is a totally viable if you
wanted to bring in a new actress and say
that she has regenerated from the last
time we saw her that that would work too
I mean that's basically what they did
with Rassilon so this this was one that
if I done this list I think even a
couple of years ago she wouldn't be on
here and that's not because I don't like
Vermont I like him on a lot but I I
resisted for a really long time the idea
of just bringing in more Time Lords it's
sort of the same issue that I have in
Superman when they bring in more
Kryptonians you know I'll accept
Superman Supergirl
Zod but like beyond that any more than
that and you're just kind of devaluing
what you have they're not they're not
last survivors anymore and they're not
as special and I felt that way about the
doctrine of the Time Lords for a while
but at this point we've already
established that Gallifrey has been
saved and is still out there and there
are other Time Lords they don't seem to
have gotten actively involved in the
universe again and I don't want them to
like ever but they are they are out
there so at this point I don't have the
same hang-up in terms of reintroducing a
character like brahmanah into the series
and again I think it would be best
served as a as as more sort of a nice
note I think it'd be nice to know where
she ended up where things were for her
or that the doctor ends up consulting
her because she knows and understands
something better than he does because
that that kind of thing did did tend to
happen or how cool would it be if the
doctor starts investigating something
and then runs into Romana because she's
already looking into it I think I think
that would just be great and finally
number one oh my god this is a this was
a recurring villain from the classic era
originally appearing in the three
doctors he appeared again in our kit and
arc of infinity where he appeared to die
but again you know he's kind of an
I'm matter creation in the first place
so you could say that after he died the
antimatter went back to the antimatter
universe I mean there are ways to bring
him back there's always ways to bring
them back now his backstory is that he
was actually one of the founders of
Gallifrey and Society was one of a
handful of people of Time Lords who
actually helped first develop time
travel in the first place but his
sacrifice involved in that was to be
trapped in the antimatter dimension and
he's uh he's bitter as hell about that
and yeah at this point bitter against
the Time Lords and at this point he has
more than enough reason to be bitter
against the doctor specifically now I
know there were a lot of plans to reveal
that the doctor was actually like either
was or was some new incarnation of
quote-unquote the other like one of the
other founding members of Gallifrey
Society I don't ever want to see that
play out I just want to make it a
comeback I think he's got a fantastic
look and he can be intimidating and it's
that nice mix of a large scale threat
because the damage that he can do just
by his presence because of the his
antimatter nature paired with how
personal his motivations can be he just
wants to exist in this universe again
but he doesn't care about the damage
that'll happen from that I think that is
the combination for a great villain I
think there are more great stories for
us to have with him that we haven't had
yet and I want to see how they update
the look of that mask so those that's my
list eight characters from classic era
who have yet to appear in new who that I
think should make the jump what are your
thoughts on the one I on the ones I've
named what ones would you add to it yes
even the Ronnie if you want to make a
case fine but that'll do it for me folks
so whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do you can support me on patreon you can
like you can subscribe and follow me on
Twitter and listen to my podcast la dee
da dee da don't know why I said that
links for all that stuff's down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]